I am a teenager I'm a teenager I'm a
teenager I'm a teen I'm a teen I'm a
[Music]
[Applause]
teen hi hi age yeah 18 18 I'm 16 I'm 16
18 16 I'm also 16 so are all of us in
high school yeah I'm a junor are you
guys oh you're a junior yeah 16 yeah I'm
a really Young Senior youngi too gr when
you turn 17 December September I was
pretty confident that the other Josh was
a teenager just because of the way he
like shook his hair around I thought
that was very like teenager this is such
like a dumb question but what's
everyone's favorite like Tik Tok Trend
right now or like sound I feel like
that'll help what is your favorite Tik
Tok Trend which I felt like was such a
generic question that I feel like that
like would like the easiest thing for
the mle to ask and fake about I like the
one that's like
like yeah I like that one yeah one that
I do remember that reminded me of that
is the one where it's like the blast
person like if you talk then you have to
pay for the bill inste going
oh my strategy is to not aggro anyone
pure defense you know just making sure
they realize I'm a teenager and that way
I can just slip through the cracks like
everyone else um any more questions what
year did you guys go to like school
during Co my sophomore year grade to
Fresh
she had the braids so I thought maybe
she was trying to like throw everyone
off and look younger than she actually
was I'm not that surprised just cuz I
noticed I was dressed differently than a
lot of the other girls and I get
mistaken for being older than I really
am pretty often like in terms of Co year
how was that for you guys cuz for me it
was in the middle of my freshman year
and then all the way through my
sophomore year mine is literally the
same as yours like yeah mine was middle
of 8th into 9th same yeah same thing
like eth to 9th it was like hard
starting high school though like on Zoom
like I feel like I just didn't know how
to like come back from that and my
grades were like fine it was more like
socially like I just didn't that's true
it was very awkward I think for me it
was my grades because I was in cheer but
I was pretty social in terms of that I
played a lot of games during classes I
would just like play Minecraft while my
like chem teacher was talking I
definitely picked up video games prior
to that like maybe I played a little bit
but after that it took off um Apex Call
of Duty Xbox I remember I'd record my
teachers lectures and then just play
games and I'd watch them back later if I
had to if I need to remember anything to
Josh's think I like exactly it was so
simple as a Josh I have a badge that's
invisible on my chest and I had to trust
him like 100% plus he just seemed like
he was just like me but taller one thing
I really hated about Zoom classes was
like breakout rooms because nobody would
talk everyone would just stare at each
other and just like be silent everyone
would just stare at each other and then
sometimes my teacher would come in and
like he'd get mad because we weren't
talking and I was like well I'm waiting
for this person to talk first I was
suspicious of Juliana because I feel
like during that round she was kind of
leading the conversation so I feel like
that might have been in order to like
waste time which is why I like try and
change the topics and kept it moving I'm
assuming you guys like everyone had here
at internet growing up cuz that's just
how it was you guys all use computers
right yeah yeah do you have any memories
like distinctly from like when you were
a kid like a video or like anything you
done on the computer that you remember
is like the thing used to play like Pap
Fria does anyone know that I still I
still play that one math game where the
guy had like the gun Johnny Upgrade I
think oh yeah no and you just run
through it till you beat the boss start
I played the run one where you like the
whole yeah thing like the like
Dimensions would slip or Flip or
something are you talking about like the
runner maze one yeah and like people put
it now on Tik Tok to like Reddit stories
it's just like you run in a straight
line like a tube right like you jump and
shs the
yeah oh yeah I was just agreeing I
really didn't play too much but I played
on my phone quite a bit and then I did a
lot of YouTube I didn't start playing
games until like how old are you when
you got a phone so I got one my in
seventh grade okay well what what like
phone was that uh an iPhone which one uh
I think it was the seven
no I got a phone when I was like I think
12 or something I got when I was like
eight I got like me too my parents are
divorced one thing I like really
remember when I was little is Minecraft
was still like kind of new so there was
like another version of it called
Minecraft light you
know it would have limits and you could
only do so much yeah you could like only
use like glass or like brick you like
The Selective blocks and dirt and grass
that's one thing I remember and then I
got like they totally remov hey think
you've figured out the mole yet well
make sure to subscribe if you think
you've got it now let's get back into
the
video Lauren was kind of just agreeing
she was like yes and I was like yes
that's suspicious
[Music]
honestly it kind of sucked being voted
out but it's the nature of the game I
guess please raise your hand if you want
to continue playing the
game how do you feel about school lunch
bad school lunch really bad it's so bad
the thing that gets me is they don't
even have water like they only offer at
least in my school they give us milk and
they have water when you were in
elementary school did they give you like
milk in a bag and you have to like
sck so I was like I don't even want to
drink this I would just starve the whole
day honestly do you have your like
school lunch line separated by year like
Junior I go to a small school so like we
all just go at the same time my school's
big but there's just one line and it's
bad like it's like a thousand person
school and there's one lunch period it's
not like we have like an A and B lunch I
know some schools have that so A th000
kids are just like pretty much yeah just
all the line like wraps around the
building my school like it was really
bad freshman year but they also there
was always like Fridays they had like
pizza you had like scheduled days yeah
like there's always Pizza always always
Pizza yeah and they get it from Papa
John's what but yeah I School I remember
the last time I had like a certain like
food item on a day was in elementary
school which made me think okay she has
to be older what shows did you guys
watch when you were younger I was like
Disney yeah it was a big Like Jesse Good
Luck Charlie Shake it up Shake it up I
didn't watch TV I was a YouTube kid but
I remember I watched Phineas and Ferb on
repeat bro actually I did watch I
watched F on repeat but I did not have
cable so I didn't watch a lot of TV I
watched a lot of YouTube right yeah okay
PewDiePie Markiplier Jack setic guy
Markiplier was a really big one for me I
still watch him what are like some
unfair things that you think people
think like about teenagers that are like
not true I was going to say like low
attention span but I have a really low
attention span like I'll fully be like
playing Minecraft and I'll have like a
show on so that's definitely not like an
unfair one like I feel like we're just
like kind of depicted to have like such
like a laziness cuz people say our
generation's like easier for whatever
like bad friend groups or something
something like just like toxic people in
general I get that I wasn't saying maybe
sensitivity like how we act on the
internet cancel
culture I would I would think I think
that's a big one cuz I think it's mainly
online where people can be like really
sensitive but I think a lot of people
just think that like everyone younger
than them is like since they have like
all this new stuff they're like oh you
are like spoiled like you have it easier
or like you're like doing better because
of us and like that's our fault for some
reason it's actually harder though cuz
we have like social media and stuff yeah
that's
Juliana
sorry I knew I was going to get voted
out especially with the the school lunch
comment I don't get school lunch please
raise your hand if you want to continue
the
game if the lights turn green you voted
the mole out and you win if the lights
turn red the mole is still in the game
and you lost one
two oh my God I trust you I trusted you
I have a oh my
God on the count of three can the mole
please reveal themselves 3 2
one I I knew you had me from the jump I
I knew it was I knew it was you because
you were lowkey silent I I got first of
all I got everything wrong second of all
I did not think it was Hannah at all so
so yeah I was like oh she's a teenager
so I'm actually a mom and I'm 31 years
old the moment that gave me away was
Minecraft my mind went blink I was
shocked to find out like she's a mother
she looks so good for
30 I got you oh I think it's what the oh
there we go yes this is Benjamin this
is wow
[Music]
yeah